thanks
um okay so uh basically i'm i'm gonna
talk about um a couple of different uh
different results in uh
line computation and how you can use it
to verify a quantum computation
uh so it's based on joint work with a
whole load of different people but
mostly elham
um
so let me jump straight in and say a
little bit about what i mean by blind
quantum computation
so the basic idea is um we want some
kind of cryptographic protocol uh for
delegated computations so we have
someone alice who has very limited
computational power
and we have uh another person bob who's
going to
be the person that the computation is
delegated to so
alice alice's limited computational
power but wants to be able to perform a
quantum computation
uh bob has a quantum computer and he's
willing to help alice uh but
alice doesn't trust bob and bob won't
hand over his device to alice so we want
some kind of cryptographic protocol that
allows alice to delegate a computation
to bob
while hiding the nature of the
computation so hiding the circuit that's
performed hiding the input hiding the
unity therefore hiding the output
okay
so
the approach we have to this problem is
based on a model of computation that's
probably quite different to
the circuit well it is quite different
to the circuit model
um
i'm not sure how many of you know the
measurement based model well
uh
lots of physicists know it but i know in
the tcs community it's
less less in vogue at the moment um
basically the idea is that you prepare
some resource state so some entangled
state of many qubits
and then the entire computation is
performed by making single qubit
measurements so you measure your first
qubit
and then you have some classical control
computer that tells you how you're going
to measure the next cubat so the basis
changes depending on the previous
measurement outcomes
and you use this to drive to drive a
computation
um so in our model what we're going to
do
because alice is computationally limited
we're going to associate her with the
control computer
and we're going to associate bob with
the preparation of this entangled state
and the performing of the measurements
but he's not going to learn anything
about this feed-forward structure about
how measurements depend on each other
okay
so in case you don't know about
measurement based quantum computing
um i thought i'd do a quick recap
basically the idea is you have a
resource state called a graph state
and the graph state can be represented
by a graph so just a set of vertices and
edges
and the way you read the state off from
from the graph
is that each each vertex represents a
qubit prepared in the plus state so an
equal superposition of zero plus one
more positive face
uh and the edges correspond to control
phase gates between the qubits
so basically each of these corresponds
to a a preparation
of a qubit and then once you've prepared
those seven qubits of the plus state
you're going to entangle them depending
on whether or not there's an edge
between them so you'll just apply a
control phase gate dependent on whether
or not there's an edge between them in
this diagram
now because the control phase gates are
diagonal
all of these operations commute with
each other so you don't need to worry
about the order they're performed on
so the qubits are numbered
and we measure them in order so we
measure qubit one first then two then
three then four and so on
and the basis that we measure
each subsequent qubit on in is adapted
based on based on the prior measurement
result
um it turns out that this is universal
for certain graph families so you can
you can pick you can pick families of
graphs that are universal as you scale
them so uh the most well-known ones are
called cluster states and they're
basically just square lattices
so they look
like this um
so if you if you just choose the uh
choose the height and width large enough
for a cluster state you can embed any
quantum circuit you want
um so a cluster state's universal
if you have measurements just in the xy
plane
and if you have measurements in the
computational basis
um it turns out though that there's
other families of graphs like this that
are universal without the need for z
measurements at all
so i'm going to give an example of one
in a few minutes that we're going to use
for our protocol
but the other important thing to know
about graph states
is that z measurements have a very
particular effect on them so if i take a
graph state here like this little chunk
of cluster state and i measured the
white vertex in the z basis so i
measured the qubit represented by that
vertex in the z basis
then the effect of this is simply to
remove that qubit
and all of the edges attached to it
okay it yields another graph state
now if i get a zero outcome it gives me
exactly this state and if i get a one
outcome i have a z correction on each of
the neighbors
but it it has this this neat effect
in fact it turns out that all poly all
poly measurements have some simple
transformation of the graph up to local
operations
and this this gives you a nice way you
can actually remove all of the clifford
uh operations within a
the clifford operations within a circuit
to just give you a completely different
graph that's then kind of algorithm
specific
okay so um
okay so what we're going to use
isn't isn't a cluster state
we want to we want to be able to hide
the computation um
and to do that
well at least initially we didn't know
how to do how to do z measurements how
to hide z measurements so we had to come
up with a resource state that you didn't
have to make z measurements on in order
for it to be universal
um so this here we call a brickwork
state mostly because it looks like the
bricks on the side of a building where
you have a brick turned in and then a
long brick and then short brick and long
brick
um so you take this graph uh you prepare
all the qubits and plus and you do your
cz
it turns out this is this is universal
for just x y plane measurements
uh and basically it's composed of these
repeating uh these repeating unit cells
uh
that have a
have ten qubits in them so five on top
five on the bottom
and then uh there so you've got two
lines of five that have their neighbors
connected and then there's two
two connections between rows
basically what's happening is
each row
is going to be a logical qubit it's
basically your wire
so during your computation your input
that starts here is going to propagate
along here
and each time each time a uh a qubit is
measured that effectively applies a
logical gate
a logical gate to that to that input
and so
you can think of it as teleportation and
your input is getting teleported along
and picking up gates as it goes
um
the the so that's that's why all of
these lines are connected because you
have to teleport from one to the next
and then the um
the the edges between rows are just to
implement entangling gates
so
the reason we're we're putting in them
like pairs here
is that we're going to take a unit
itself
and
we're going to have two untangling gates
in it and then we're either going to
make them cancel out or not cancel out
depending on whether we want to place
a
an entangling operation there so let me
uh let me show you how you can use this
to implement some gates
uh i won't go through the details of the
teleportation and how how you get these
because it just i won't be able to fit
it on the talk
otherwise
um but basically uh if you
measure this at an angle alpha in the xy
plane
then this one angle beta and the xy
plane then gamma and the xy plane and
then x
the effect of this is to implement
um
basically a z rotation through alpha and
x rotation true beta and then a z
rotation through gamma
and basically here what's happening is
that you're teleporting this it picks up
a hadamard and then it picks up another
hadamard so the two hadamards cancel out
and then the two control zeds these two
edges between rows cancel out so that's
why there's no entanglement there
so you can use this to implement various
gates like hadamard
power brake gate or the identity gate
of course you can implement them in
parallel as well
but you can also use it if you choose
your measurement angles a little bit
differently so instead of measuring
these two qubits both in zero in x
uh if we measure one of them in y
instead
then we're able to get a control not
gate
so if you go through all the
teleportations and the gates it picks up
this this bit of uh this bit of
brickwork state here
gives you a how to mark from the first i
had a mark from the second which you're
going to cancel out
uh you've got your cz here
between these two which is this gate
here
uh your pi over two gives you a z
rotation true pi over two plus a
hadamard
then the zero gives us a hadamard and
then we've the control z at the end and
similarly on the bottom you've got these
uh pi over two rotations
in the z basis and if you go through
this the gates cancel out the hadamards
cancel out here
um so you get these uh these rotations
the control z then
changes whether or not these two cancel
out
so if the control is zero these cancel
out and you get the identity if the
control is one then these are going to
give you an x skate
uh so when you take that together it
gives you a c not gate
so that means if we go back
uh we can choose what unit tree we want
in each of these blocks from that
universal set so how to mark by a right
identity or
control not and obviously we can choose
control not in either direction because
these uh these unit cells are mirror
symmetric
okay
so that's basically
how you can implement a measurement
based computation with only x y plane
measurements on a brickwork state but
that doesn't tell you anything about
hiding information so we haven't really
gotten to the point of the talk yet
so
uh let me try to get to the point uh so
supposing we start out with a um
with a resource state like this so this
is just the graph statement we saw
earlier
uh so if we write it out from the
constructive definition each of these uh
vertices are pluses
uh each of the edges are cz so we fill
them all in we get something like this
and then our computation is going to
progress by us measuring in some basis
in the x y plane perhaps some angle phi
one and getting some measurement result
to m one and then we measure another
angle phi 2 and then m2 maybe we also
have some z measurements in there
and we get m4 and so on you go through
it that way and each angle phi or z it's
gonna the the basis for that measurement
is going to depend on potentially on the
previous outcomes so on m1 m2 m3 and 4.
so this is this is just a measurement
based computation
so we're going to start modifying it now
by adding in some redundant operations
so this is just expanding it out so
these x y plane measurements i'm now
writing all of my measurements as being
in the z basis
and i'm just writing in the rotation
first followed by a hadamard if it's an
xy plane measurement and if it's a z
basis measurement well we don't need to
perform any unity
okay so
so far so good
then what we're going to do is we're
going to add in some redundant rotations
so we take our input qubit
we rotate it by theta one
and then we counter rotate it we were
going to rotate it by phi one right
but this rotation by theta one and
sorry it's a z rotation i should have
put in a subscript but these are all z
rotations so this commutes with the
control z
with the control phase gate so we're
really rotating by theta and then
rotating by
phi minus theta so the two thetas cancel
out
so this is still the same operation
these two are equivalent i'm just doing
a redundant uh
a redundant rotation
um so that's
that's straightforward then what we can
do is um
we're going to add in a a pauli z gate
which is just the same as
adding a random multiplica sorry a
random
multiple of pi
into our z rotation here
so if we do this
if we have our our z rotation we
we apply a z gate
uh depending on some bit r1
then well this commutes with everything
right except for the hadamard so the z
comes through the hadamard it becomes an
x and that flips our measurement result
so our measurement is now going to be
uh m1 but it's going to be xored with r1
okay so
so far this still implements a
measurement based computation you just
need to be careful that you compensate
for these r1s
by doing the xor on your measurement on
your on the outcome of your measurements
and what we're going to do is we're
going to associate
alice with the preparation of these
input states
so they're all single qubit states that
aren't entangled
and we're going to associate bob with
this intermediate and tangling step
and measuring step and then we're going
to let alice do these xors at the end
okay
um but there's still a problem
right so what we've done is we've
commuted through the measurements
uh the z measurements all the way
through
through the control z operations to the
start
uh so that's that's fair enough but that
means that bob
knows he's going to know that there's
something special about these qubits
because he's not being asked to measure
them
but because they're already measured
which is effectively the same as just
generating a random bit and sending it
to bob
we're just going to ask him to measure
them anyway
okay so we're giving we're gonna add in
these redundant measurements that we
just discard
so now you can see from bob's
perspective at least he's just
entangling according to some particular
graph
and then he's performing all of these
measurements all in the x y plane
in some angles delta 1 delta 2 delta 3
delta 4 or delta 5 that he's told by
alice so alice is going to compute the
deltas and tell them to bob and then
alice is going to look at these results
that bob sends back b1 and compute the
actual measurement results from it by
xoring it with r1
okay so the the protocol goes as follows
alice generates these input states
uh which i'm calling psi i so they're
either they're either these plus states
with a z rotation applied or they're
randomly zero or one
uh if she wants to make a z measurement
on that cubit
okay so uh she sends the states to bob
bob places them in uh
in a rectangular array and then
entangles them according to the to the
brickwork state graph so he's just
applying the c's ads
uh they don't show up so great on this
but anyway
um so what what's going to happen is the
protocol is going to go back and forth
with purely classical communication now
where alice for each qubit i
alice is going to compute some delta i
which is the measurement angle for that
qubit
uh minus the random rotation initially
applied to it and send it to bob
bob is then going to
measure that qubit
in the basis
given by
well
in the basis that's an angle delta i in
the xy plane
and then he's going to
return the result vi to alex and then
alice will use that to compute mi which
is just what would have been the
measurement technologies
okay
uh so that's that's basically it and
doing this alice can run a measurement
based computation and the claim is that
bob isn't going to learn anything about
the computation that's been performed
okay
so
how do we formalize this well one way we
can do it is we can say a protocol is
blind
uh
on input x while leaking at most lx if
the distribution of the classical and
quantum information depends only on lx
so what do i mean by while leaking at
most lx
well
the protocol has to leak some
information
because bob sits down and he does a
computation with his hardware and he has
some bounds on the resources he used
so you can't help but reveal an upper
bound on the dimensions of your
computation
so bob knows how many qubits he used and
he knows how many gates he applied
there's no getting around that
uh now you can pad it so he uses more
than he needs but you can't make him
think he used less than he actually did
so in our case the protocol is going to
leak the dimensions of the circuit
okay
so
we're going to take um
so for uh for qubits
well let's try and show this is true
there's two types of qubits
in our in our protocol there's the z
measured ones and there's the ones
measured in the xy plane which will be
the bulk of the cubans
so let's show first for the xy plane
qubits
so what does bob receive
well he receives some certain number of
qubits and the dimensions of the
brickwork state to tell them how to
entangle it
but beyond that all he receives is for
each qubit in for each vertex in that
graph he receives a single qubit in this
state
um
plus theta i plus ri so that's just
a rotation a z rotation of theta i plus
pi r i
uh applied to the plus state
okay and ri is going to be uniformly
random in zero or one is depending on
alice's key
and then uh he's going to receive a
correction angle delta i which we said
is phi i which is the actual angle you
want to use to implement the computation
minus theta i which was this
part of this random rotation
okay
but if we look at it we see the only
thing that happened the only
bit of information that depends on ri is
the single cubit
none of the classical information
depends on our eye
so we can trace over our eye and that's
going to give us a
a maximum mixed state for this single
cub
okay so that's always going to be in the
maximum mixed
state uh independent of what the
computation is independent of theta
independent of phi and so on
and then we look at at delta i and we
see well okay although although when we
write this state out we had a theta i in
it because if we trace over ri alone it
becomes independent of theta
we can then see that only delta i
depends on theta i
and so if we randomize over theta i
we're going to yield the maximum mixed
state for the for the deltas so you're
going to get a uniform distribution of
the deltas
independent of the actual angle to be
measured
so from bob's perspective all he's going
to see
is he's going to get the dimensions of
the brickwork state and he's going to
get some number of qubits that sums to
the the product of those dimensions
um which are all independently in the
maximum x state and he's going to
receive angles which are all uniformly
distributed independently
okay
but yet when you go through the protocol
alice is going to obtain the right
result at the end because we just
obtained it straight from the circuit
for a measurement based computation by
just adding redundant stuff that
cancelled out
okay so what about the z basis states
well here we're sending a cubit that's
either
well we said we prepare a plus state and
then measure well that's the same as if
we just randomly choose to send a zero
or a one and keep track of what we sound
so alice is going to send zero or one
randomly chosen and
the measurement of that qubit well
that's just right that's just uniformly
randomly chosen because we added them in
we don't care about them they don't do
anything so both of these pieces of
information are again going to be
uniformly distributed
so they satisfy exactly the same
distribution as for the x y plane qubits
so our protocol is going to be blind
while leaking at most the dimensions of
the circuit
okay
um
this isn't uh this isn't a terribly
complicated uh definition of blindness
but it turns out that you can take this
this definition of blindness and show
that it satisfies that it's equivalent
to a composable uh a composably secure
definition
um but i'm not going to try and do that
now because i don't have time
um okay so verification
the basic idea is
we want to be able to check if if we
delegate this computation we want to
somehow use the fact that bob doesn't
know what's going on to test whether
he's being honest with us so
we have a whole load of ways of doing
this that are not quite a long paper but
this is the simplest way
uh it doesn't yield the best uh the best
detection rate but uh but it's the
simplest to explain the basic idea is
that you take a you take the brickwork
state and you wrap it around a cylinder
so that it has so that it has
periodic boundary conditions at the top
and bottom
okay
and what we're going to do is we're
going to randomly choose a qubit to act
as a trap
and that trap is going to be used to
detect if bob cheats in that location or
not
so
we choose our we choose a trap location
uniformly random
and we prepared the the state in plus
theta
sorry plus uh theta t plus rt so um
we're just randomly choosing a rotation
in the xy plane
to prepare our state
so it's going to be at some location
now we don't want it to mess up our
computation
so what we're going to do
is we're going to
identify a tape that contains that
that trap cuba
so by a tape i just mean two two
neighboring uh two neighboring rows
uh such that if i prepare all of these
all of the others if i measure them in z
they're going to disentangle this uh
this trap qubit from the rest of the
graph
um and we can always do this if if this
had been over here
instead i would have had to pick the
the row above it instead but you can
always do it with two neighboring rows
so
we do that and what what it does is it
yields this disentangled uh trap qubit
and the remaining qubits in the
computation which are still on this
brickwork state that's wrapped around
the cylinder but with this this strip of
two rows removed
okay but we can just rearrange the
qubits and that's the same as having our
original brickwork state and this
disentangle track qubit
okay so my claim is then
that if you measure this trap cubat
uh you're probably and you decide
whether you're going to accept the
computation or not depending on whether
this matches
the value you expect for it
then the probability of you accepting an
incorrect outcome is bounded by 1 over n
where n is the number of qubits if we
measure all the qubits
and if we don't measure if we have some
quantum output then it's going to be 1
over 2n
and
importantly
the detection isn't going to depend on
the computation that's performed
so your probability of detecting it is
completely independent of the
computation
uh because it only depends on whether
the trap was disturbed
okay so a sketch of how you prove this
we can write down
a general adversarial behavior so we
have some quantum input that's received
from alice here
without loss of generality we can assume
that bob
actually does the entanglement and the
rotation into the measurement basis
before applying his deviation operator
okay so this is just some general
unitary that acts on the input space and
the angle received from alice and some
ancillar register that bob has
so the uh
so we do this uh each time the reason
that we can assume that he acts
correctly is just that it's a unitary
operation and so we can always uh absorb
its inverse into u1
and u2 uk and so on
so we go through it that way it turns
out that this is a bit messy to deal
with because there's all back and forth
interaction so we want to get rid of
that so instead we can just
treat it as a sum over comp over
computational paths and treat each path
separately and that allows us to
effectively remove the interaction
so that gives us something like this
where we have moved all of this
deviation to the end and those operators
change
but but we get this at the end um
and so
we can group all of them together into
this operator i'm writing as u prime
so
if we apply
the result we know uh
about how this disentangles
how the trap disentangles from the rest
of the graph
it's going to give us something like
this so we have an input state
uh
which goes in that's prepared in plus
theta t plus rt
uh it goes in u prime is applied to it
on the rest of the stuff which who cares
what state the rest of the stuff is in
and then it's measured in the
computational
basis to result in some bt
so first we can
expand u prime as a sum over
poly operators
and we can look at what happens with
each poly operator
and each one is either going to act
trivially or non-trivially
on this wire here that contains the trap
cubit
okay but the only ones that can lead to
us accepting an incorrect outcome are
when the hamming rate of the operator is
uh
is at least one
right so the the identity term well
that's not going to deviate you from the
from the correct protocol
uh so the only things we care about are
the non-trivial poly terms
and if we only care about those then the
probability that the trap contains that
poly error is at least one over n
and it's gonna
it's it's potentially greater than this
depending on the weight of uh of sigma
but it's at least one over m
so if if uh if sigma flips the outcome
uh at the trap site then it's definitely
detected
and if it doesn't flip the outcome then
it's not an error
because it wouldn't have flipped another
outcome
so it wouldn't have generated an error
so it's only these sigma i terms only
the the local poly operators that
actually yield an incorrect measurement
result that will
that are errors that need to be detected
um otherwise they could be like
stabilizers of the state or something
like that
um
if if you have some quantum output
uh you could have your trap in your
quantum output and okay alice then needs
some way to measure that so you can
imagine it may be going off to a third
party or being returned to alice and her
measuring that particular qubit
then the probability of detecting the
error is one over two instead of one
and that's because if i apply an x error
then this uh this plus theta t it might
be in the plus state in which case it
won't detect an x error
or it might be in a y eigen state in
which case it will definitely detect the
error or it could be some angle in
between and when you average over them
you just get a factor of one over two
okay so that's that's basically it um
yeah this this doesn't this only depends
on the location of the trap it doesn't
matter what was going on the other wires
so this gives us something called
independent verifiability so
if alice reveals whether it was passed
or not it doesn't reveal anything about
her underlying computation and again
that's something that's important for uh
that's something that's important for it
to be composibly secure if you don't
have that property then you can leak
information by revealing whether or not
you accept it
um okay so uh thomas asked me to say
something briefly at the end about open
problems
uh so uh okay so the the big open
problem in this area is whether or not
you can verify a quantum computer with a
purely classical verifier uh with a
single quantum computer so i guess the
other talks we've heard today relate to
verifying quantumness when you've had
two entangled provers
uh and uh and i've talked about this
kind of semi-quantum verifier and a
single approver what if we only have a
single prover and a classical a purely
classical verifier
so uh can we can we check the results
then
and
a smaller kind of precursor problem you
can think of is whether it's prob
whether it's possible to do blind
computation in the setting without
trying to verify anything just hiding
the computation that's going on because
if we could come up with a way to do
blind computation that way well then
maybe we could also find a way to use
the blind computation to hide some traps
um
okay so that's that's pretty much it i
was just going to say the kind of
barriers to doing this one problem is
the difficulty of hiding information
in the to prover setting you're hiding
information because you're telling some
stuff to one party and some stuff to
another party and neither one gets to
know what the other was told
in our setting you're hiding in kind of
quantum uncertainty because you're
sending these non-orthogonal states to
the approver
um when you have a purely classical
verifier and only a single prover
there's no way to do either of these
tricks so
the prover is going to get a transcript
they're going to get a set of
instructions
that completely determines what they do
and what has happened in the protocol
um
so that's kind of problematic it also
means that we can't rule out classical
simulation
so
if if
if the prover simply has a sufficiently
large classical computer
they could just simulate the the quantum
dynamics of what they should have done
given this classical input because
nothing is hidden from them
um
yeah then
the last ones i was going to say is
there is an issue with
with a one-time pad not being enough to
hide information in the setting
and the reason for that is so in in our
computation you can kind of think of it
that the input and output are
encrypted because they have these random
poly operators applied to that
the problem in this setting though is if
you have a complete transcript of the
protocol you can run it again and again
and again and again and you can perform
tomography
and this means that you can distinguish
the probability distributions over
classical states
you can't tell which classical state a
particular probability corresponds to
but you can look at those amplitudes of
those probabilities
and just their distribution you can
write a histogram of them so for example
if i give you a plus state
if i give you some instructions that
result in a plus state or a minus state
or i give you some instructions that
result in zero or one even though on a
single run this would result in a
completely mixed state if you run it
again and again and again you can
distinguish those two cases
and in general if you want to hide this
if you have quantum output and you want
to hide it perfectly you need you need a
computation you your decoding operation
needs to be as complex as the circuit
you're performing
uh so that
that kind of represents a significant
barrier
unless you start increasing the size of
the hilbert state adding in kind of
random mancillas that are entangled into
it or not but that's something that
would have to be a component of any uh
of any protocol that achieved this okay
sorry that's me done
sorry if i went over time thanks very
much
so why do you believe ip of vqp is equal
to
you just you think it should be true um
i don't know but it's true uh it's an
open question
maybe it's not fair
well
we've kind of looked at it two ways now
so um so we've looked at it and uh
darius looked at it and others from this
point of view of this some
semi-classical uh
verifier and then
uh umesh and ben and folk have looked at
it from the these chsh games
uh so where you have two provers and in
both these cases it seems that you get
exactly bqpp
so
i guess it's interesting to ask if if
you remove either one of those
restrictions whatever you get whether
you can get down to uh down to
an interactive proof for bqp or not
um we don't
i don't know either way
uh i've been kind of trying to think how
to do it i think i have some ideas maybe
but i'm not sure
your first barrier um
in the case of um
ben stock and you know how he would
achieve delegated computation using many
provers so there's a clear principle
behind this which is
this rigidity phenomenon and you're
taking advantage of the no signaling
principle then as you said you know
you're
sort of hiding information in this new
significance
here it's interesting you mentioned
something you said well
i was wondering i wanted to ask you
if there was also a clear principle
behind this approach so a single prover
approach and you mentioned something
about using non-orthogonal we're using
non-orthogonal states we're using the
fact that you can decompose the
maximally mixed
single cubic state in many different
ways
um and we're we're using that to encode
our gate
um so you can use this non-technology to
to hide information as well in a in a
kind of similar way
but you don't um
can you relate it to
you know like a violation of chsh
inequalities like one of these
fundamental things so there's you can
relate it to some uncertainty principle
that you'd be using or
um you you can i mean you can think of
it as measuring half of an epr pair
right so if you you prepare some epr
pair you've uh two qubits coming out of
it
and you you measure one in some basis
you do
or z
the result of this outcome is exactly
the distribution that we send to uh
this is exactly this will get in our
language this will give us our
our ri and this would give us the state
uh
plus theta
i so
um so it's yeah i mean it's like
measuring half an epr pair in the same
kind of way that there's this kind of um
correspondence in
in qkd that you can you can think of
you can think of the echo protocol and
the bb-84 protocol as being uh
different ways of viewing the same thing
so yeah
there's something going on there for us
but we're not using chs games for
verification in in ours we're just using
the no signaling property
i have a question regarding the first
open problem that we keep because
so is there any uh
is there any like let's say like any
language in bqp for which there exists
some non-trivial protocol like some
example
i mean other than p
i don't know like
i mean it depends right i mean if if
graph non-isomorphism happened to be in
bqp then then you'd have a protocol for
that
what about factory
yeah sure yeah yeah so anything that's
in the yeah anything that's in the
intersection of pqp and mp
also has a has a
has a trivial so uh there's this paper
by matt mccaig i think he has a protocol
for recursive foreign sampling
of this form
okay
yeah so yeah i mean i guess uh certainly
you can you can find
maybe some uh some sub
languages but um
certainly uh bqp as a whole seems to be
open actually i think scott is still are
you still offering 25 dollars for that
yeah
it's probably worth less for inflation
than when i first offered it but you
know whatever
all right let's thank you again